now you're from Boston so you you from
the safe suburbs ever since Good Will
Hunting came out everybody thinks
everyone from the Boston area lived in
Southie and got into fights and smash
bottles over people's heads when you
think of Boston what comes to mind
world-class universities the Irish
marky-mark likely influenced by the many
iconic films set there but movies like
Good Will Hunting and The Departed
didn't come up with the Boston identity
out of nowhere it comes in part from the
history of the city itself a history
largely defined by the conflict between
working-class Catholics and the
wealthier protestant elite in the 18th
and 19th century the Boston ruling class
consisted exclusively of British
Protestants associated with elite
Cambridge universities but in the
eighteen hundreds thousands of Irish
immigrated to Boston and threatened the
Protestant control the Boston community
responded with systemic discrimination
early loss in Boston outright banned
Catholicism and Irish people couldn't
attend Ivy League schools poor Irish
communities were relegated to South
Boston below the Charles River but as
their numbers grew Irish people gained
political control of the city 20 years
after an Irishman couldn't get a [ __ ]
job
we had the presidency the Boston Irish
history created a cultural identity
around being the underdog even though
they became the ones in power and it's
from the old conflict between Protestant
and Catholic British and Irish and
Cambridge and South Boston that we see
where Boston stereotypes come from so
let's get into it well because you have
the same kind of background what
background are you from the same
neighborhood who's who's Southie the
subtext of Good Will Hunting is the
conflict between the Cambridge elite and
poor Irish Catholics the film regularly
establishes Southie as Irish through
color scheme the opening shot shows an
Irish flag over Will's fireplace the
next several shots all have some form of
that green white and orange color scheme
associated with the Irish flag the most
compelling example in the beginning is
the green white and orange
buildings they drive past but the color
scheme is also in the shot of the old
woman on her porch the characters even
wear them Chucky's with his white and
green jacket and will with his orange
and maroon one all these shots
established Southie and the people in it
has Irish and throughout the rest of the
movie they constantly surround
themselves with green Irish imagery in
gritty neighborhood bars the neon sign
next to Chucky is a shamrock with
Southie written inside it and all these
Irish blue-collar areas are the exact
opposite of this it's polished perfectly
matching and elitist instead of the
Irish flag shots of the Cambridge elite
have American flags in the background we
see this imagery most prominently in the
Harvard bar behind the pretentious
Harvard student and of course as Chucky
tries to impress the girls with his
knowledge he has a Guiness sign behind
him in the movie the American flag is
always associated with the people at
odds with the poor Irish from Southie
there are American flags behind the
intellectual elite the justice system
and big government and the film
regularly places will within that
conflict fighting the pressures to
become a certain type of American ideal
Sean's office is the room where will
comes to terms with his past and figures
out what to do with his life it's no
coincidence that this room has both an
American flag and Irish paraphernalia
the film establishes the specific
Cambridge Southie conflict in Boston but
it doesn't really give a solution for it
instead of deciding either to remain in
Southie or get a white-collar job will
abandoned the conflict altogether and
goes out west by making this maneuver it
carefully sidesteps the conflict between
the elites and the Irish he doesn't have
to pick a side but not every Irish movie
has clear Irish and American imagery
like in Good Will Hunting some movies
show the conflict in different ways
Manchester by the sea shows the class
divide in Boston although it does only
take place in the Greater Boston area in
the opening montage Lee works as a
handyman in a southern Boston suburb
that night he goes to a bar and has a
staredown with what the script describes
as two businessmen he then starts a
fistfight with them it's no coincidence
that the movie establishes Lee as
blue-collar and then right after that he
picks a fight with two white collar men
but a more unexpected conflict happens
later when patrick visits his born-again
mom and her new fiance jeffrey the scene
shows how the irish in boston also stand
out by being catholic instead of
protestant Zalman Patrick
nobody's trying to recruit you in the
1800's laws in Boston discriminated
against Catholics while the legal
distinction is long gone the cultural
differences between Catholics and
Protestants have stayed Manchester by
the sea uses this religious conflict to
reinforce the emotional distance between
Patrick and his mother it's a subtle
distinction rarely seen in Boston movies
but it's still an underlying component
of what makes Protestant America feel
different from Irish Catholics it's
worth noting that before the mother gets
her life together she's a drug addict
who abandons her family it's a pretty
common trope in Boston movies to have a
blue-collar identity in women come off
as unseemly while in men it's charming
in Gone Baby Gone
Helene McCready's character is a junkie
and an irresponsible mother so the
characters in power decide what's best
for her and her daughter whether it's
the detectives or her working-class
brother-in-law everyone seems to want to
take away Holland's agency compared
Helene to Madeleine in The Departed
Madeleine is educated and wears a
Harvard t-shirt indicating that she's
upper-class [ __ ] superior because she
went to college for Colin Sullivan she's
his trophy for breaking free from his
Southie background women in Boston
movies are commonly either deserving of
pity or a status symbol there are
another way for Boston movies to create
distinct differences between groups I'd
argue that you can even see a subtle
difference between the two groups in
something as simple as coffee fancy
coffee is for snobs and outsiders why
don't you
for the hell is it cafe latte what the
dilemma and Dunkin Donuts is for the
average American like the mayor of
Duncan's the faces right
I like Dunkin Donuts but have you been
to a Dunkin Donuts it doesn't have a
homeless guy standing in front is that
part of the design plans even though
Dunkin Donuts is actually a popular
nationwide chain it's become a signal of
blue-collar people in film and TV so in
the case of a Boston movie people who
drink Dunkin must also be from Southie
it's the same as Dunkin Donuts cost 15
times the price but Irish imagery
religious differences and taste in
coffee only show up in some of the
Boston movies there is one symbol of the
Southie Cambridge conflict but almost
every Boston movie has the Charles River
look at every Boston movie understands
that the Charles River separates the
elites from the poor when the poor Irish
people want to do a hit or a robbery or
go to their day job there is always a
shot from Southie looking north towards
the Charles River at Cambridge or
downtown Boston as expected in the town
the camera starts south of Boston and
the first robbery is in Cambridge right
outside the Harvard subway station and
this geographic distinction is
historically accurate Irish immigrants
often crossed the Fort Point channel and
Charles River to work in blue-collar
jobs for academic and to upper-class
institutions Boston movies have always
established this division but they
challenge it differently depending on
the movie in movies like The Boondock
Saints the town and Mystic River the
Irish decide to operate outside of the
system that oppresses them and take a
law into their own hands they fulfill
the fantasy that a person doesn't have
to subject themselves to the unfairness
of the current legal system instead they
criminally work around it forming their
own gangs who exploit or take down the
system a system represented by cops the
government or the upper class in these
Boston movies it's always us versus them
but all this stereotyping and
generalizing begs the question are the
lines that clearly drawn according to
The Departed they're not when I was your
age they would say we could become cops
or criminals today what I'm saying is
this when you're facing a loaded gun
what's the difference instead of
fighting the system the department tries
to infiltrate it from within the film
quickly establishes the two groups early
on instead of Cambridge elite society is
represented by the Boston State House I
mean you move in your upper class by
about Tuesday
unlike Will Hunting Colin wants to rise
into upper society what are you looking
at and because he's not a super genius
he's held back by his background on his
way oh forget it
your father was a janitor his sons only
a cop so you're a cop yes a police
detective I'm one more oh yeah that's
right fancy Colin's a criminal just like
the characters in other boston movies
but with one big difference he's trying
to go legit
despite the blurring of groups and the
characters attempt to rise above his
origins in Southie the movie has a
depressing message but if you're a rat
and you're from Southie no matter how
much you try to rise up you'll pay the
price families are always rising a
fallen in America am i right
who should that Hawthorne and for Billy
Costigan it's all the same even though
he tries to do the right thing how can
families dog another Southie projects
like ticks three deca men at best I know
your father are you trying to say that
he was nothing I'm saying he worked at
the airport I know what you are okay I
know what you are and I know what you're
not I'm the best friend you have on the
face of this earth and I'm gonna help
you understand something you punk you
know [ __ ] car the tragedy of The
Departed is that despite how hard the
characters tried to escape the
circumstances of their birth they still
suffer the fate of a common criminal
when they were born into a lower-class
Irish family in the south of Boston
their future was sealed
but the departed and all other Boston
movies missed the true reality of the
Boston Irish they did escape their roots
in Southie and did make their way to the
Statehouse after the Irish gained
control the wealth discrimination the
religious conflict and the geographic
separation of the rich and the poor
still existed but the Irish became the
leaders of Boston and in doing so they
gradually turned what was once a
marginalized identity into an identity
that the whole city embraced so movies
about Boston focus on the memory of
Irish people as the underdogs
who struggled to overcome their
repression by the Cambridge Elite Good
Will Hunting and other Boston movies
become so iconic because they understand
this Irish underdog story and to the
success of Good Will Hunting made this
Irish identity understood outside of
Boston now Boston Southie and the Irish
are inseparable
[Music]
Matt Damon and Ben Affleck made such a
groundbreaking movie by placing their
own fictional story within the actual
Boston environment of the 1990s they
achieved the perfect balance of truth
and style that many Boston movies have
since tried to emulate this balance is
something I think about when I write
these videos make it flashy but keep it
true author Susan Orlean talks about the
importance of finding your style when
writing nonfiction as the writer of the
book that inspired the film adaptation
she clearly understands how a great
story uses elements of truth to deliver
its message she speaks at length about
creative nonfiction storytelling in an
amazing original series on Skillshare
Skillshare is an online learning
platform with thousands of classes and
creative writing video editing and more
Premium Membership lets you use classes
that fit your interests and you have the
option to get the annual subscription an
awesome deal that comes out to less than
ten dollars a month but if you're not
ready to commit yeah just click on the
link in the description and get two
months of free access you can see Susan
Orlean class and thousands of others
across tons of topics a big THANK YOU to
Skillshare and to my patreon supporters
who make this channel possible